also breaking this morning at 6 33 a
murder investigation metro police on the
scene of a crime that happened earlier
this morning they're there right now
this one tropicana and spencer hector
mejia has just arrived moments ago
hector what are you seeing and hearing
so far
we just got an update from metro police
no suspect description right now that
investigation unfolding just about a
block away from us right there in that
parking lot at the tropicana royale
apartments a 26 year old male shot and
killed found inside of a vehicle
police tell us they have reason to
believe this is a targeted incident but
again the shooter nowhere to be found
police right now looking for the
public's help and this is lvmpd's third
homicide investigation just in the last
24 hours but they do not believe that
any of these three homicides are related
again police still searching for the
gunman we'll let you know as soon as we
get new details from police reporting
live hector mejia live local now hector